was hat ein Mann ohne Beine Erdnüsse
ich lösche meinen Kanal ne hallo mein
Name ist Luca meine lieben Freunde wisst
ihr dass mein Humor ziemlich am Arsch
ist
von daher ist der Humor meiner Fanpages
auch tendenziell eher am Arsch und
dementsprechend wird auch das komplette
Video heute für ein Arsch kann ich in 15
Sekunden bisher so oft Arsch sagen drei
Fanpages von mir ihr seht die Namen hier
eingeblendet schaut da gern mal vorbei
machen extrem beschissene Content diese
drei Fanpages kamen auf die glorreiche
Idee eine instagram-gruppe zu erstellen
namens Flachwitze und da haben die jetzt
Sprachnachrichten reingeschickt mit
flachwitzen die ich mir anhören soll ich
gehe mit gar keinen Erwartungen in
dieses Video Minecraft Filme Blockbuster
[Musik]
warum fliegen Vögel im Winter in den
Süden weil es schneller geht als laufen
oh mein Gott
ich hasse euch so doll ich habe aber
auch einen guten Job was versteht man
unter einer Turbine
gar nichts viel zu laut
deutlich besser
[Musik]
und los wir kommen alle in die Hölle ja
wie gut ist besser
ich hasse euch so doll was ist grün und
stellt viele Fragen Günter Lauch
es ist nicht so dass ich lache weil es
witzig ist sondern weil ich lache weil
ich
habe gestern den zeitungssum verprügelt
denn wir Auszeit muss natürlich auch
einstecken können
es ist einfach schade
welche Idioten meinen contentfeiern
über den Acker ein Kaninchen
das war mit Abstand der schlechteste
Witz bisher was ist das Gegenteil von
Flachwitze steilwitze
ich glaube ich werde eure Namen einfach
an Instagram weitergeben
so dass die euch blockieren das ist der
Unterschied zwischen einem Arzt und
einem Polen der Pole weiß was dir fehlt
erzähl mal rassistisch was ist die
Lieblingsspeise von Piraten
es erinnert mich an den Job den ich im
Podcast gebracht habe dass die
Lieblingsfrucht von Cristiano Ronaldo
Orangen sind wegen dem hohen Vitamin C
Gehalt wie nennt man einen Delfinen
Unterhose Slipper
ich will das nicht mehr verdammt jetzt
ist meine Uhr runtergefallen ich darf
sie nur nicht aufheben denn ich habe
keine Urheberrechte
meine Familie ist sehr musikalisch meine
Schwester ist zum Beispiel schon direkt
bei der Geburt flöten gegangen
das können wir nicht reinschneiden was
sucht einen einarmiger in der
Einkaufsstraße nach einem
Secondhandladen
ihr seid richtig kleine
nicht in Worte fassen wie cringe dieses
Video ist welche Autofahrer sind total
nett Geisterfahrer sie sind total
entgegenkommend
was ist braun knusprig und läuft mit dem
Korb durch den Wald brotkäppchen
einfach dein Maul Jessy was ist denn das
schon wieder für ein kackwitz
brotkäppchen absolut beschissen
was ist der Unterschied zwischen Tennis
und banditumping beim Tennis hat man
zwei Aufschläge
und ist schwarz-weiß ein springuin
für was sorgt eine Spinne für ein tolles
Netzwerk
ey ihr seid doch wirklich am Arsch sagt
eine schwangere Frau beim Metzger ich
bekomme drei Kilo gehacktes
was alle Kinder gehen über die Straße
außer Rolf der klebt im Golf
ich sehe schon wieder kommen dieses
Video hier ist nicht werbefreundlich
auf der Arbeit Werner 57 unfallchirurg
das geht nicht mehr ich habe auch so
viele ich würde sagen wir machen mal
lieber ganz kurz eine Pause
e aber
super schöner backpulin meine Damen und
Herren oder so ein bisschen erhaben 3D
mäßig sehr sehr schöne Materialien so
ein schönes vintage blau mit einem Print
vorne drauf happy und ich bin jetzt auch
glücklich denn wir machen weiter mit dem
nächsten Witz das wichtigste Ausbruch
deswegen
schweißaus Scheiß
aus halt's Maul wie nennen Kannibalen
Skelette Leergut komm egal das ist so
das finde doch niemand witzig
Bademeister geht in Rente er hatte eine
klorreiche Karriere eine chloreiche
sorry
also wir haben uns ja schon mal gesehen
auf Fantreffen
aber wenn ich euch noch mal sehe dann
Kacke ich euch ins Zimmer eigentlich die
Stimmung in der DDR sie hielt sich in
Grenzen ach komm Mona verpiss Dich
verpiss Dich hey was sagt ein Pirat wenn
er trockenes Gras sieht ahoi
was ist weiß ungesund und fliegt über
die Wiese die Biene Maja
das ist klein braun und klopft an die
Scheibe ein Baby im Backofen
ich muss euch alle Sperren danach
Schauspieler spielt keine Rolle
das ist hier wirklich ganz unterste
Schublade kommt die Polizei nicht wenn
adidas überfallen wird es sind schon
Streifen vor Ort
wenn Ihr an meiner Schule gewesen wärt
ne
ich hätte gesagt Mobbing komm da ist es
wirklich meine gute Idee
warum bist du so hart darauf dass andere
klappe ich bin eine Kiwi
okay hat mir gestern ein neues Dach
gekauft ging aufs Haus
komm nee was ist der Unterschied
zwischen Chinesen und Japanern Chinesen
Lächeln Japaner strahlen
wegen
okay
[Musik]
was machen zwei Biologen im Knast sie
teilen sich eine Zelle wie nennt man
demonstrierende Veganer Gemüseauflauf
ich lache über so einen dummen scheiß ne
das ist geht gar nicht warum kann man in
New York kein Schach spielen es fehlen
zwei Türme
ich habe beim Bäcker angerufen aber der
ging nur die Mailbox ran oh nein
ey wer hat euch in euer kleines Erbsen
Gehirn Geschiss vom letzten 45 jetzt
hier machen wir uncut durchkommen das
ist 10 m lang und hat keine Zähne eine
Bolognese im Altersheim
okay geht ein Cowboy zum Friseur kommt
raus ist sein Pony Weg kenne ich schon
beißen zwei dummen Eisenbahnschienen
sagt der eine borsen die hart sagt der
andere geh doch da hinten hin da ist
eine weiche der war auch nicht gut zum
Schluss möchte ich noch gerne
Laserdrucker grüßen okay liebe Grüße
laserluca ich grüße Mona hi Gott ich
würde an der Stelle einfach nur das
Video beenden und mein youtube-kan